-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden signed
an executive order today
that increases background checks
on gun purchases.
From now on, gun dealers
are gonna ask your first
and last name.
[ Laughter ]
Republican presidential hopeful
Nikki Haley
said on Sunday that taxpayers
"should absolutely not bail out
Silicon Valley Bank."
But I think that's
largely because
it's polling ahead of her.
[ Laughter ]
The Pentagon said today
that a Russian jet
crashed into a U.S. military
drone over the Black Sea.
And I think I speak for
all Americans when I say,
probably an accident, right?
This doesn't have to be
a whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
Just go with accident.
Russia is reportedly
restoring hundreds
of decades-old Soviet tanks
to use against Ukraine
amid a shortage of weapons
and equipment.
Oh, they are struggling.
Next it's just gonna be,
"Any way to trick out
these T-shirt cannons?"
[ Laughter ]
Fox News host Brian Kilmeade
interviewed Florida governor
Ron DeSantis over the weekend
and played catch
while wearing suits.
It kind of ruined the flow
of the interview, though.
"So, Governor, what do you think
the U.S. role should be
in the war in --
Oh, wait, car!"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Fox News aired
an interview over the weekend
where host Brian Kilmeade
played catch
with Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
at a high school baseball field
in Iowa.
And no surprise here,
their fathers chose
not to come out of the corn
and reconnect with them.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats are reportedly worried
that efforts to ban TikTok
could make it harder
to reach young voters.
Well, you could do
what Republicans do
and reach them on Venmo.
[ Laughter ]
Just a thing that happened.
I don't know why everybody's
so weird about it.
Former president Trump
has reportedly been invited
to testify before
a New York grand jury
as part of the Manhattan
district attorney's
investigation
into hush-money payments
that were made to
adult film star Stormy Daniels.
And despite everything,
Trump was still excited
to get invited to something
in New York again.
[ As Trump ] I'm back, baby.
Any -- Any word
from the Met Ball?
Have they reached out?
[ Normal voice ] California
congressman Mark Takano
recently reintroduced a bill
that would make a 32-hour
workweek a national standard,
which would finally
give Americans
the free time they need
to look for a third job.
[ Laughter ]
Microsoft is set on Thursday
to hold a "Future of Work with
AI" event, and this is scary --
None of the executives
can remember organizing it.
[ Laughter ]
"Playboy" is reportedly planning
to relaunch
as a digital-first magazine,
and, dude, I just found
my dad's stash in his closet.
[ Laughter ]
"The New York Times"
published an op-ed today titled
"Working From Home Is
Less Healthy Than You Think."
Oh, how unhealthy could it be?
I mean -- Oh!
Oh, crap.
Is that a ghost?
[ Laughter ]
The NYPD is looking
for a group of teens
who allegedly stole more than
$40,000 worth of calculators
from high schools in the Bronx.
Said the teens,
"Actually, it's...
$41,672."
[ Laughter ]
That's how you do it, right?
In my -- In my --
In my mind's eye,
it also had that little
paper thing that was...
And fin-- Alright.
We're gonna go --
[ Laughter ]
Oh, boy.
How hopeful are you guys
based on this photo?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a clam was recently
discovered in Florida
that's believed to be
more than 200 years old.
And like most 200-year-old clams
in Florida,
it moved there from
the Upper West Side.
You guys, we just --
That was the monologue.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's officially a monologue.
We got a great show
for you tonight.
He's an Emmy-winning actor and
the star of "The Blacklist,"
which hits 200 episodes
this Sunday.
The fantastic James Spader
will be here.
Friend of the show James Spader.
You know him from "Deadwood"
and "American Gods."
He's currently starring
in "John Wick: Chapter 4,"
which is out next weekend.
Ian McShane is joining us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And she is a fantastic comedian.
She stars in "The Ms. Pat Show"
and is kicking off her "Ya Girl
Done Made It" stand-up tour.
Our friend Ms. Pat
will also be here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Before we get to all that,
these days, the news stinks.
I don't have to tell you that.
Every headline I see makes me
feel worse than the last.
Every once in a while, there's a
story that makes me feel great.
I'd like to share one
in a segment
called "The Kind of Story
We Need Right Now."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a Eurasian eagle-owl,
but it's not just any
Eurasian eagle-owl.
This owl's name is Flaco,
and last month he was
minding his own business,
living in the Central Park Zoo,
when some vandals cut a hole
in his enclosure
and Flaco did what any
self-respecting owl in captivity
would do -- he escaped.
That's right.
Flaco Shawshanked
out of that cage,
which according to one article
was the size of a bus stop
and which he'd been living in
for 12 years,
and he started flying
around Central Park.
This is the kind of story
we need right now.
Every New Yorker dreams
of moving out
of their tiny [bleep] apartment
into a nicer neighborhood,
and Flaco did it.
Every New Yorker wants to live
on Central Park.
Suddenly this dude was living
in Central Park.
Without a trust fund.
Incredible.
Also, Flaco had been living
next to the penguin enclosure,
and if there's one thing
every New Yorker
has had to put up with
at some point,
it's living next to somebody
who eats a ton of fish.
My man Flaco
escaped a nightmare.
Not long after Flaco
left the zoo,
he was spotted on Fifth Avenue
peering in the window
at Bergdorf Goodman.
Of course he was.
He spent 12 years
living in Manhattan.
Never got to see the sights.
That's why he was also spotted
at the Statue of Liberty,
at the M&M's store, and in
the front row at "Hamilton."
There he is.
Probably a montage
of him somewhere
trying on a bunch of outfits.
Flaco's escape created
an exciting opportunity
for him to spread his wings.
But more importantly,
it created an opportunity
for reporters to say owl puns.
-It's a "Hoodunit."
-"Hoodunit."
-Hoo-hoo-hoo-dunit.
It's a "how did you not
come up with something better
than that?"
I love that they don't even
come up with different puns.
It's like they're all
using the same copy
of "Bartlett's Puns
for Reporters."
But the best part
of this whole story
is everybody
underestimated Flaco.
When he first escaped, an owl
expert told "The New York Times"
that Flaco would be easy
to catch because,
in his experience, owls
were not particularly smart.
Oh, yeah? Then why are they
the only birds who graduate?
[ Laughter ]
Authorities were worried Flaco
wouldn't be able to feed himself
in the wild
because he had spent
his whole life in captivity.
Well, guess what owls eat.
Rodents and birds.
Worrying an owl will starve
in Central Park
is like worrying a toddler
will starve
in a chicken nugget factory.
Flaco did just fine on his own
because Flaco's not a dumbass,
but zoo officials were still
determined to get him back.
So they set up
an elaborate ruse.
They left a dead rat
out in an open field,
and they put it inside a trap,
and then they played a recording
of owl mating calls
to lure Flaco to it.
And you know what happened next?
Flaco swooped down,
grabbed the rat,
but didn't stay long enough
to get caught in the trap.
But he did stay long enough
to look directly at a camera
and pose.
Look at his face.
I don't know Flaco, but I'm
pretty sure that face is saying,
"Do I look like
a [bleep] idiot?"
[ Laughter ]
The zoo officials were like,
"We shouldn't tell anybody
about this."
[ Laughter ]
They made several more attempts
to catch Flaco.
They followed him around
Central Park with nets.
The NYPD even tried to catch him
with a dog crate.
Nothing worked.
And pretty soon New Yorkers
started putting pressure
on officials
to just leave Flaco alone.
And after weeks of trying
to catch him,
zoo officials did just that.
They announced they would end
their attempts to capture Flaco
and let him be free.
This is the kind of story
we need right now.
Everyone underestimated Flaco.
They said he couldn't survive
on his own.
He did it.
This is a story
for the underdogs,
a story for anybody
who's ever been told,
"You're too short
to play basketball,"
or, "Girls can't do math,"
or, "J.Lo is never gonna
date you a second time."
So tonight, you walk
through Central Park,
look up at the sky.
You just might see
something amazing.
You might see Flaco flying free
with a rat in one talon
and a "Hamilton" playbill
in the other,
'cause this is the kind of story
we need right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]